madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
cette journée marquée par le sourire des
sept astronautes de discovery l'équipage
a relevé le défi faire oublier la
catastrophe de columbia en transe sains
et saufs sur terre
l'atterrissage a eu lieu en début
d'après-midi en californie les
commerçants du littoral font leur compte
les français dépensent rémois en
vacances on cause l'augmentation des
prix qui les amène à surveiller leur
porte monnaie
y at il un relâchement de la sécurité
sur les routes de france la question est
posée après la hausse du nombre de morts
au mois de juillet certaines
associations estime qu'il y à eu
cacophonie dans la communication du
gouvernement la présence des gi's en
irak de plus en plus contestée par
l'opinion publique américaine george
bush doit faire face à la colère des
mères de soldats qui réclament le retour
de leurs enfants ella rae d'envoi de
réservistes et que la fin de ce journal
nous découvrirons un jardin
extraordinaire à cavalaire dans le var
un agencement de plantes venues de pays
au climat méditerranéen presque des
tableaux et on commence par cette image
synonyme de soulagement pour la nasa et
pour les américains il est 14h12 hors de
paris quand la navette discovery touché
sort de téléphonie après 14 jours dans
l'espace et plusieurs records l'équipage
pl est enfin rentré à la maison pascal
golomer quand le bras il y a deux heures
à peine il fonçait à plus de 25000 km
heure à travers l'atmosphère et les
voilà desservant de leur navette comme
si de rien n'était les sept membres de
l'équipage traîne même le temps
d'inspecter le dessous de l'appareil et
ce bouclier de carbone dont une faille
avait été fatale à columbia il ya deux
ans et demi rien de tel aujourd'hui
mission accomplie nous sommes six
cantons dead sont revenus pour dire à
quel point cette mission est un succès
dit le commandant elin police nous avons
approvisionner la station spatiale
internationale que les tests prévus et
ramener l'année avec un bon état
un retour exemplaires en effet il est 5
heures 12 du matin en californie et à la
minute près discovery se pose sur la
piste d'edwards la nasa aurait préféré
un atterrissage en floride à cap
canaveral
la météo en a décidé autrement dans la
salle de contrôle à houston
pas d'explosion de joie juste un grand
ouf de soulagement
félicitations et bienvenue à la maison
un cap canaveral c'est le soulagement
aussi le personnel de la nasa a dû
suivre tout cela à la télévision mais
peu importe l'essentiel c'est que la
navette et son équipage sont de retour
après 14 jours de tension je ne
m'attendais pas à être aussi ému parce
que j'ai assisté il ya deux ans et demi
à la catastrophe de columbia et de plus
nous avons travaillé d'arrache-pied avec
des gens qui se sont donnés à fond
quelques instants plus tard les grands
patrons de la nasa qui étaient venus eux
aussi à cap canaveral pour accueillir la
navette ont célébré leur succès devant
la presse mais sans triomphalisme n'est
pas une tâche facile de faire voler
c'est la belle miss la promesse que nous
faisons aux amériques ainsi que nous
ferons tout notre possible pour que
chaque fois ce soit un peu plus facile
mais la nasa a suspendu tous nouveaux
vols de navette
tant qu'on n'aura pas résolu le problème
de l'effritement des réservoirs au
décollage à peine l'euphorie du retour
passé l'heure est déjà aux
interrogations sur la suite du programme
en attendant l'amérique a trouvé ces
nouveaux héros cinq hommes et deux
femmes dont et lynn collins
à 48 ans cet astronaute chevronnés était
la responsable de cette mission c'est
elle qui a pris les manettes à
l'atterrissage la nasa l'avait choisi
pour son expérience et son sang-froid
and guéri
juste un salut discret à l'évidence la
dame a le triomphe modeste
il n collins vient de réussir un
atterrissage sans heurts tout en douceur
aux commandes d'une carlingue 200 tonnes
discovery
c'est une histoire comme l'amérique en
raffolent avec une héroïne
il est une colline la première et unique
femme à commander une navette 48 ans
6300 heures de vol les astronautes
l'appel rennes le rock temps elle
affiche sous une apparente décontraction
une volonté de faire un sang froid que
rien ne semble perturber
pour preuve aux commandes de discovery
elle a une mission faire oublier le
drame et l'échec après la désintégration
de columbia réussir à tout prix
l'enjeu ne lui fait pas peur nous allons
prouver que l'on peut monter à nouveau
dans une navette en toute sécurité et
nous sommes confiantes de l'inébranlable
il n collins quand après 14 jours
la nasa reporte à deux reprises
l'atterrissage pour l'instant vous
demander de bien roulant servait la
terre et plus de faire un ou deux tours
de plus on va nulle officiellement
l'atterrissage pour cette fois guère
reçu houston on comprend bien que le
temps est instable en floride est
d'accord on se refait un tour de la
terre
c'est que madame le commande ont un
parcours d'excellence sans faille fille
d'un facteur elle devient à force
d'obstination et de travail pilote dans
l'armée
les pilotes de chasse elle intègre la
nasa en 1991
quinze ans plus tard elle diriger un
équipage de sept astronautes
il n collins a bien l'étoffé des héros
et dans la vie elle est mère de famille
assurément
l'amérique peut encore rêver vos succès
personnel pour ellen collins et défi
relevé pour la nasa l'atterrissage de ce
matin fait un peu oublier la catastrophe
de columbia en 2003 reste que les
américains semblent prêts à abandonner
les navettes habitées très coûteuse pour
se concentrer sur l'objectif lune et à
plus long terme la conquête de mars
nicolas le marinier et jean yves blanc
26 juillet dans la fumée et les flammes
discovery quitte la terre un détail
vient gâcher la fête
un morceaux d'isolant qui s'arrache du
lanceur ah bein l'engin oblige les
astronautes a joué les mécanos de
l'espace la navette est elle encore
viable depuis l'accident de columbia en
2003 la nasa a dépensé un milliard de
dollars pour améliorer la navette
celle ci est indispensable pour terminer
la construction de la station spatiale
internationale
nous allons effectuer deux vols cette
année ensuite quatre ou cinq vols par an
jusqu'à ce que la station spatiale soit
achevé et ensuite la navette sera mise à
la retraite d'ici 2010 au plus tard
il ya tellement de risques dans ces vols
tellement de peur qu'on se fait à tort
ou à raison que la nasa ne veut plus
prendre ces risques là et puis surtout
elle veut mettre tout l'argent pour les
activités sur le plus long terme le long
terme c'est d'abord une base lunaire
permanente en 2018
un avant poste de la conquête de mars
vers 2020
la remplaçante de la navette elle est à
l'étude un engin plus sur place et au
sommet du lanceur
c'est la technique des vols apollo et
celles utilisées pour protéger les
cosmonautes sur les fusées russes
si un débris se détache au lancement il
ne peut pas tombé sur le véhicule
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas en 1970
le vol apollo 13 failli coûter la vie à
ses trois astronautes en cause
l'explosion d'un réservoir au décollage
en france les commerçants font leurs
comptes les français auraient tendance à
moins dépenser cet été pendant leurs
vacances pouvoir d'achat en baisse des
prix qui augmentent les vacanciers font
attention à leurs moindres dépenses
exemple d'arcachon david béziers bernard
bonne arme sur la plage d'arcachon les
parasols sont de plus en plus serrés les
vacanciers sont bien au rendez-vous mais
regardent de plus en plus leur porte
monnaie comme le constate tous les jours
le patron de cette pizzeria qu'ils
partagent des plats de plus en plus ça
peut être une viande ça peut être une
salade voilà ils vont pour quatre ils
vont prendre deux trois flacons pas
prendre un clash a qu'un les desserts
c'est vrai qu'on va en vendre un petit
peu moins voilà
car même si elle est nombreuse la
clientèle des vacanciers a tendance à
être à l'affût des petits prix est très
attentif aux tarifs pratiqués comme
l'avait dit verre de glace 2 on le cuit
verglacées dans deux jours
on aurait peut-être fait des balades en
bateau et puis on a peut-être pas parce
que quand c'est un peu cher ensemble
ardemment batum
on est toujours quand même cas que
un peu cher dans le budget autre
tendance les longs séjours sont en voie
de disparition a réservé de semaine dans
un gîte au lieu de trois auparavant donc
savait que maintenant ça que tellement
cher que
donc on réfléchit bien où est ce qu'on
va aller pour pas tranché en fait à
l'office du tourisme
on ne pense pas cependant que la saison
sera mauvais ya beaucoup de personnes
dans la création beaucoup de vacanciers
une dépense moins au quotidien parce que
certains ont déjà passé des courts
séjours à partir du printemps dont ils
ont fractionné leurs dépenses et leur
budget vacances
mais le temps est fini où vacances était
synonyme de dépenses sans compter le
touriste 2005 est avant tout un
consommateur en maillot de la
mobilisation générale sur les routes de
france est le mot d'ordre lancé
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement après
l'annnonce de la hausse de 7% du nombre
de tués en juillet dominique perben a
rappelé l'objectif de passer à moins de
5000 morts en 2005 mais certaines
associations estiment que le relâchement
des automobilistes s'explique notamment
par la cacophonie gouvernementale au
sujet de la poursuite ou non de
l'installation des radars loïc de la
mornais christelle martin 5 vies
emportées dans ces carcasses c'était
vendredi dernier à rochefort à la sortie
d'une boîte de nuit après avoir fêté un
anniversaire et pour avoir grillé un
stop
cinq jeunes de 15 à 26 ans sont morts et
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont tombés 566
victimes sur les routes pour ce mois de
juillet contre 529 l'an dernier à la
même époque une augmentation de 7% la
plus forte enregistrée depuis trois ans
ces dernières années justement la france
avait fait d'énormes progrès grâce à une
politique très répressive sur les routes
mais aujourd'hui les associations
mettent en cause nommément le nouveau
gouvernement craignant que cette
augmentation ne soit directement lié au
très mauvais effets produits par la
cacophonie gouvernementale
à partir du 20 juin dernier quand toute
la presse a relayé des propos démentis
par dominique perben mais qui aurait
annoncé que on allait marquer une pause
plus gras d'art terminé les feux de
croisement ouvert
allumés de jour et tout ça a été perçu
comme un relâchement de la politique de
sécurité routière le mois dernier
dominique perben avait été retoquée en
conseil interministériel
il souhaitait une pause sur
l'installation des radars automatiques
dominique de villepin a tranché pour les
propositions de nicolas sarkozy aux
mille radars prévus fin 2005
s'ajouteront donc 500 nouveaux radars
l'an prochain
pressé de rectifier le tir et sommés de
rejouer aux gendarmes
dominique perben a assisté cet après
midi à un contrôle routier en vendée je
tiens compte et a131 mais le ministre
botte en touche sur les cafouillages du
mois dernier
il ya eu un débat sur les radars en 2006
éventuellement ce débat a été le
dépasser en deux jours mais ça n'est
évidemment pas cela la question
ce qu'il nous faut faire c'est faire en
sorte que chaque français et chaque
français se sentent concernés et se
sentent acteurs de la politique de
sécurité routière
au lendemain de sa réélection jacques
chirac avait fait de la sécurité
routière l'une des grandes causes
nationales de son nom darwish
voudrais marquer ce quinquennat par
trois grands chantiers mais qui ne sont
pas de pierres et c'est d'abord la lutte
contre la sécu contre l'insécurité
routière je suis absolument horrifiés
par le fait que les routes françaises
sont les plus dangereuses euros vitesse
alcool stupéfiants ou voiture plus
puissante depuis un an 5181 français
sont morts sur les routes le nombre de
blessés lui a diminué mais si les
accidents se font un peu plus rares ils
sont par contre plus violent et plus
meurtrier attaché systématiquement votre
ceinture à l'arrière et chaque été le
mois d'août est considérée comme une
période de relâchement des
automobilistes sur la route des vacances
les contrôles sont donc renforcé durant
la saison estivale
la sévérité d'autant plus d'actualité
que les derniers chiffres on l'a vu son
mauvais françois jullien pieds-noirs et
christophe la rocca ensuivie une
opération de contrôle dans la région de
marseille
nous faisons sur les faits et a pas de
panique madame les contrôles sont
renforcés
mais il n'y a rien à vous reprocher
seulement un rappel de la sécurité les
enfants toujours attachés et un enfant
dans un pare brise
c'est pas terrible brisée c'est une
famille de brice et j'étais attaché je
suis en règle au niveau de mes batteries
y est j'ai pas vu donc mais pas de
cadeau au mois d'août pour les ceinture
non bouclée les pointes de vitesse ou
les voitures surchargées 5 à l'arrière
dans celle-ci 180 euros d'amendé ce
n'est pas tant les mauvais chiffres du
mois de juillet qui justifie ce contrôle
mais plutôt les vacanciers car en
vacances la tête est ailleurs
donc moins sur le volant alors on se
relâche entreprises dans la voiture
c'est certain et feu est en vacances
pour une bonne partie de nos concitoyens
ont fait certainement bien moins
attention aux règles habituelles radar
pas radars les pouvoirs publics ont eu
du mal à se décider sur l'installation
de nouvelles machines automatiques les
automobilistes s'y sont habitués
les radars automatiques pour maarten
voix antilles c'est un peu je dépensais
jamais la voiture que je n'ai pas
dépassé les gens se disent bon
entraîneur c'est bon on n'est plus un
but des radars donc on peut ré accélérer
et en prenant vitesse jusqu'au prochain
panneaux levé donc le pied bouclez vos
ceintures éteignez vos portables pour
éviter la menthe bien sûr mais surtout
pour ne pas mourir bêtement sur une
route un mois d'août 67 départements
sont aujourd'hui concernés par des
mesures de restriction d'eau la
sécheresse touche quasiment tout le pays
et l'association de défense des
consommateurs l'ufc que choisir lé enfin
un pavé dans la nar elles estiment que
la politique de gestion de l'eau est une
aberration en france théaux souvent
frédéric capron des jets d'eau qui
fonctionne en plein après midi c'est
interdit dans les yvelines mais
apparemment cette commune ne le sait pas
dans 67 départements particulier commune
et golfe sont contraints de limiter leur
consommation d'eau mais aujourd'hui ce
sont les agriculteurs et en particulier
les producteurs de maïs qui sont pointés
du doigt l'association ufc que choisir
accuse certaines agences de l'eau de
laisser toute liberté à ses producteurs
pour irriguer leurs champs
exemple en adour garonne l'été
l'agriculture 7,1 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau dix fois moins l'eau potable
est cinquante fois moins pour
l'industrie or dans cette région le maïs
représente près de la moitié des
cultures nous ce qu'on demande c'est
qu'il y ait des redevances fixes et pour
inciter les agriculteurs à se
reconvertir et il faut que cet argent
perçu auprès du monde agricole reste
intégralement dans le monde agricole et
servent à aider aux reconversions pour
d'autres productions agricoles mais pour
les agriculteurs une hausse des taxes
est inconcevable il ne se sentait
absolument pas coupable de la sécheresse
ou nous faire ici ou là la remarque d'un
véhicule turquie kirill en plein soleil
alors celui là peut-être faut-il lui
taper sur les doigts
le pénaliser le sanctionner mais je
pense qu'il faut pas mettre tout le
monde à la même enseigne
je crois qu'il ya une démarche
respectueuse des ressources en eau de de
l'environnement de la part des
agriculteurs et il serait temps d'en
tenir compte
malgré tout ufc que choisir souhaite que
l'assemblée nationale s'implique dans la
gestion de l'eau en france et souhaite
une diminution forte des cultures de
maïs
un incendie a détruit aujourd'hui 120
hectares de la forêt de brocéliande en
bretagne le feu vient d'être fixé c'est
le massif le plus important de bretagne
cette forêt le berceau de la légende du
roi arthur et des chevaliers de la table
ronde
alors pour l'instant dans le sud de la
france l accalmie mais les sapeurs
pompiers savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
compter sur les canadairs toujours
immobilisé une semaine après le crash
mortel en corse
les appareils ne pourront reprendre du
service qu'après les premières
conclusions techniques de l' enquête
pour comprendre l'accident on est
maintenant obligé de reconstituer les
débris de l'appareil et ce sera fait à
partir de demain christophe widemann
zidène berkous dispersés dans la
montagne corse les débris du canadair
quelques heures après le crash des
éléments précieux pour l'anc est
d'autant que la boîte noire n'a livré
aucune information sur les causes de
l'accident pour tenter de comprendre ce
qui reste du canadair va être
hélitreuillé demain des pièces de
plusieurs tonnes comme la queue et une
partie de la carlingue vont être
rassemblés dans un hangar militaire à
calvi un puzzle géant pour les experts
qui pourront ainsi analysé l'endroit où
le canadair a été sectionné ce moment là
que ces experts pourront nous donner un
échéancier pour rendre deux premières
conclusions
en attendant ses premières conclusions
les dix autres canadair restent cloués
au sol et sont un après l'autre inspecté
méthodiquement pour l'instant aucune
trace de choc lors de l'accident du 1er
août
il pourrait donc s'agir d'un problème de
structure ou d'un défaut d'entretien de
l'appareil qui se serait brisé de lui
même en plein vol il faudra encore
attendre plusieurs jours au minimum pour
que les experts se prononcent et pour
que les canadairs puissent reprendre
leurs vols
au portugal la saison propice aux
incendies n'est pas encore fini mais on
parle déjà de désastre écologique
les pompiers sont toujours mobilisés
pour lutter contre les flammes qui ont
ravagé 2500 hectares au coeur de la zone
protégée d'un parc naturel dans le
centre du pays
depuis le début de l'année 68 mille
hectares sont déjà partis en fumée des
dégâts considérables qui s'explique en
partie par un manque de moyens pour
débroussailler et entretenir les
terrains boisés face à se laisser aller
des habitants et des élus
les pompiers ne peuvent rien reportage
high speed dans le centre du pays
dirt ecochard amis très beaux arts
manuels en tounes venait de moderniser
son affaire un garage de voitures qui
marchait bien je ne peux pas encore vous
nous attend pour séduire sa couleur les
voitures de ses clients elle aussi en
brûlis manière lente ou n'est ce n'est
pas assurée il n'a pas encore annoncé la
nouvelle aux propriétaires des voitures
je n'en retirerai que quand j'aurai plus
de courage que je peux chanter pour
pouvoir négocier avec eux avant nord
depuis plusieurs jours les reprises de
feu tourmente les villageois ici à
quelques dizaines de mètres d'une
ébénisterie après avoir éteint un
incendie
on trouve dans les cendres un allume feu
de cuisine sans lui je ne peux pas vous
répondre mais un objet comme ça ici
c'est bizarre
soixante dix suspects ont été arrêtés
par la police judiciaire en trois jours
dans le pays
pourtant il apparaît clairement que
l'essentiel des incendies est due à de
simples négligences
il y à bien et loi qui oblige les
propriétaires forestiers à
débroussailler leurs parcelles
mais rares sont les gens consciencieux
le feu prend toujours au sol sont
vraiment les branches ci ont
débroussaillé régulièrement on en
arriverait pas cette calamité selon une
étude récente réalisée par des
spécialistes de l'environnement
ici au portugal on compte sept fois plus
d'un syndic en espagne à 20 fois plus qu
en italie et 22 fois plus qu'en dresse
les précisions cela fait six fois plus
qu'en france pour les dix dernières
années le temps s'est légèrement
apaisées entre la communauté
internationale et l'iran au moment où
l'agent ce nucléaire de l'onu se
réunisse et à vienne l'iran a laissé la
porte ouverte à un compromis et à des
négociations avec l'union européenne la
france elle se dit prête à tendre encore
une fois la main à l'iran après
l'annnonce de la reprise de ses
activités nucléaires
la préférence des gi's en irak de plus
en plus contestée par l'opinion publique
américaine
george bush doit faire face à la colère
des mères de soldats qui réclament le
retour de leurs enfants ella rae d'envoi
de réservistes
plus de 1800 gi's ont trouvé la mort en
irak depuis mars 2003 mais la maison
blanche l'envisagent pas de retrait
avant l'été 2006 bernard lebrun c'était
hier soir aux etats unis
à cleveland ohio une petite ville sur
laquelle le destin s'acharne
c'est une veuve qui entonne l'hymne
américain cérémonies officielles sans un
mot de protestation vingt soldats de
cleveland sont morts en irak depuis la
fin du mois de mai pour la seule semaine
dernière quatorze soldats et officiers
de la base de broc parkes sacre yvelines
ont trouvé la mort dans une attaque
suicide
une tragédie qui suscite colère et
incompréhension genre télé d'ici je ne
sais pas comment mais sur télé d'ici et
cette maman là elle a décidé de passer à
l'acte depuis trois jours elle campe
devant l'entrée du rance du président
bush
elle veut le voir en qualité de mère
d'un soldat tué en irak la bonne route
une office scandent ces familles des
vétérans pourquoi at il tué mon fils
pourquoi mon fils est il mort son fils
cassez est mort en avril dernier à
bagdad
cinq jours après son arrivée aujourd'hui
même est décédé dans cette rue de la
capitale irakienne le 1800 25e soldats
américains dans cette énième attaque
suicide
les chances de survie sont très minces
aujourd'hui pour les 123 mineurs chinois
toujours bloqués dans une mine au sud du
pays près de canton
aujourd'hui plus de six cents sauveteurs
sont mobilisés pour tenter de secourir
ses hommes pour la plupart ce sont des
anciens paysans pauvres des provinces
voisines
les mines chinoises sont considérées
comme les plus dangereuses du monde
mais le charbon assure 70 % des besoins
énergétiques de la chine au brésil ce
sont des cambrioleurs de haut vol qui
viennent d'effectuer un cas sans
précédent dans le pays
ils ont dérobé au moins 65 millions de
dollars au siège de la banque centrale
un vrai travail de pro au romain clément
une banale société de jardinage juste à
côté la banque centrale de la ville
c'est à partir de cette couverture que
les malfaiteurs ont creusé un tunnel
pendant près de trois mois sans jamais
éveiller de soupçons
la seule chose que je savais c'est
qu'ils entraient et sortaient souvent
ils disaient qu'ils avaient du travail
c'est la seule chose que je savais en
tant que voisin
c'est ce tunnel long
2 80 m éclairer consolidé compte
emprunter ce week-end les braqueurs
un ouvrage qui les mènent directement
dans la salle des coffres de la banque
et leur permet de s'emparer du butin 68
millions de dollars pour un poids total
de 3 tonnes et demie les employés de la
banque n'ont découvert le casque lundi
matin l'oeuvre selon la police d'une
équipe de six à dix hommes très
professionnelle très bien renseignés
ayant sans doute bénéficié de
complicités à l'intérieur de la banque
les caméras de surveillance les
détecteurs de mouvements n'ont pas
fonctionné à l'heure qu'il est les
malfaiteurs sont toujours en cavale est
en possession du butin
ce matin une cérémonie du souvenir était
organisée à nagasaki au japon le 9 août
45 trois jours après hiroshima
la ville était dévastée par une bombe
atomique américaine 74 mille personnes y
ont trouvé la mort en france après les
récentes évasions de détenus
hospitalisés dans des établissements
psychiatriques le ministère de la santé
veut trouver des solutions pour
améliorer la sécurité
il a réuni aujourd'hui tous les
directeurs concernés xavier bertrand a
répondu à la demande des syndicats
en annonçant des moyens supplémentaires
nathalie sa peña dominique bonnet 250
directeurs d'hôpitaux psychiatriques
réunis au pied levé par le ministre de
la santé en plein mois d'août à paris le
monde de la psychiatrie secoué par une
série d'agressions et d'évasion avait
besoin d'être réconforté pour renforcer
la sécurité dans les établissements
le ministre promet dont 44 millions
d'euros en 2006 pour l'achat de systèmes
de sécurité et l' embauche de personnel
nous faut avant tout rassurer les agents
pouvoir protéger les patients mais aussi
mais aussi savoir rassurer la population
sur ces questions xavier bertrand
s'engage également à accélérer la mise
en place du plan santé mentale annoncé
en février mais toujours virtuel 17
millions d'euros sont débloqués dès
aujourd'hui pour recruter 700
infirmières et 450 lits dédiés aux
détenus seront créés d'ici 2008 au sein
d'unités spécialisées et garder une
lyon de longue date les détenus en crise
parfois dangereux sont aujourd'hui
soignée avec les autres malades sans
surveillance particulière ces mesures
sont bien accueillies par les
psychiatres
notre souci à nous c'est que les
hôpitaux psychiatriques reste quand même
malgré la paix avec une meilleure
protection une meilleure sécurité reste
effectivement ouvert et puisse continuer
à travailler et faire du soin les
hôpitaux psychiatriques ne seront donc
pas transformé en prison
même s'ils doivent être mieux équipé
pour accueillir des détenus souffrant de
troubles mentaux
quelle est donc la réalité quotidienne
dans un hôpital psychiatrique modmyi
novaes mathieu dreujou se sont rendus
dans un établissement de pontoise en
région parisienne les problèmes
d'insécurité font partie du quotidien le
personnel doit notamment gérer les
hospitalisations de détenus envoyés par
les prisons du secteur derrière cette
porte 25 malades mentaux interne et
l'entrée toujours verrouiller le service
psychiatrique et le plus sécurisé de
l'hôpital en cas de violences extrêmes
d'impatience et la chambre d'isolement
en fait ces gens de son attention
les internes hier qui ont pris six
distribue les traitements ne sont jamais
à l'abri d'un dérapage petit nombre de
patients mais qu'en plus elle est très
important pour sécuriser l'espace
la chambre est donc totalement aseptisé
et laporte partiellement vitrée permet
de surveiller le patient à toute heure
mais l'important pour ce psychiatre ce
n'est pas une caméra de plus ou de moins
la sécurité vient d'abord d'un manque de
personnel 3 3 infirmiers l'effectif pour
l'unité ou compreniez que quand ils
viennent à 2 voire le patient qui est
ici il ya plus qu un seul infirmier pour
les 24 patients restants la moindre
urgence dans ce cas devient difficile à
gérer d'autant que les infirmières ne
suivent aucune formation spécifique pour
travailler en psychiatrie les réflexes
apprennent sur le terrain l'angoissent
ne se dit pas elle est sous jacente et
quand on fait des nuits là c'est sûr que
là on
on a un peu plus peur parce qu'on est en
émoi nombreux freins a recours à la
chambre d'isolement mais on n'est que
deux donc c'est toujours la nuit qui est
la plus inquiétante en fait à quelques
pas seulement de l'établissement une
prison c'est l'autre principales sources
d'insécurité dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques car la loi les oblige à
internet ou détenu considéré comme
malade mental dans le sas de la maison
d'arrêt dont nous nous livre un détenu
par fois très agitée qui va très bien
très délirant et pour le transporter on
ne dispose que des véhicules de service
du personnel qui souvent féminins dans
ces conditions comment travailler en
toute sécurité sans revenir aux anciens
d'asile fermés ou se transformer en
prison nous poursuivrons ce soir notre
rappel des faits divers non élucidées
aujourd'hui nous revenons sur la mort de
géraldine giraud et de son amie katia
lherbier
les corps des deux jeunes femmes ont été
retrouvés chez un homme qui est
aujourd'hui le principal suspect mais
les policiers n'ont obtenu aucun aveu ce
dossier comporte encore beaucoup de
zones d'ombré amaury guibert jean
françois arnaud
neuf mois après la mort de géraldine
giraud et de son amie katia lherbier
garde une grande part de mystère de
victime et peu de certitudes à la
toussaint les deux jeunes femmes passent
quelques jours dans la maison de la
famille giraud dans l'yonne le 1er
novembre au soir elle se serait rendu en
voiture à sens sur la route à 20h10
géraldine giraud reçoit un appel sur son
portable
c'est le dernier signe de vie à 20h30
arrivées probables dans cette maison de
sens sous habib katia lherbier
à 21h50 à villeneuve-sur-yonne
un homme retient de l'argent avec la
carte bancaire de géraldine giraud
il s'agit de jean pierre treiber arrêté
le 23 novembre
sans travail fixe l'homme vit seule dans
cette maison que les enquêteurs
perquisitionnent au fond d'un puisard de
cadavres les corps de géraldine giraud
et katia lherbier
tout semble l'accabler mais jean-pierre
kreber ni le double meurtre
c'est à la la poursuite aux enquêteurs
de démontrer que c'est lui suite à la
présence des corps dans son puisard que
c'est lui qui les a tués et pourquoi et
comment
dans quel but quel est son mobile mais
au fil des interrogatoires ces questions
ne trouvent pas de réponses et d'autres
interrogations apparaissent la cave de
la maison deux sens était le lieu du
crime
des traces d'un gaz toxique et ont été
retrouvés le même qui a tué les deux
jeunes femmes
jean-pierre très vert se trouvait-il ici
mais surtout comment at il croisé la
route des victimes
nous remercions les conditions dans
lesquelles jean-pierre treiber aurait pu
rencontrer géraldine giraud et katia
lherbier éventuellement par
l'intermédiaire d'une tierce personne
qui pourrait peut-être être un complice
puisque cette piste de la complicité
n'est toujours pas écartée d'autant que
sur le ruban adhésif qui a servi à
bâillonner les victimes deux adn
inconnus ont été découverts et ils
n'appartiennent pas à jean pierre
treiber le principal suspect qui de sa
prison évoque deux mystérieuses à mont
noir une zone d'ombré de plus dans le
dossier
après les incidents qui ont touché de
bus circulant au gaz à nancy à
montbéliard certaines municipalités
s'interroge sur la fiabilité de ses
véhicules c'est le cas de la ville de
nice où la moitié des cars roulent au
gaz naturel
un audit a été demandée nathalie jourdan
gaëlle caron en grimpant sur ce marché
pieds les niçois ont une chance sur deux
de monter dans un bus roulant au gaz
depuis les récents incidents impliquant
ce mode de transport
ils n'ont pas changé leurs habitudes
j'ai roulé plusieurs années dans ce
genre de stage ici
au point de vue écologique ça pouvait
être bien mais si c'est au détriment de
la santé des personnes elle n'a fait du
tout hein comme ceux de montbéliard et
nancy les bus niçois sont équipées de
fusible thermique
il fonde à 100° pour pouvoir libérer le
gaz des bonbonnes fixées sur le toit
comme ceux du gaz naturel
il est plus léger que l'air par
l'atmosphère le seul phénomène qu'on
peut observer c'est qu'une flamme puisse
rester accroché sur le fusible qui
sauvèrent un système qui n'a pas empêché
d'explosion à montbéliard les
exploitants du réseau ont donc procédé à
quelques contrôles vérifier thomas et le
dispositif de sécurité est d'ailleurs
les huissiers extérieurs agréés et tous
les six mois en interne technique en
attendant les résultats de l'enquêté de
montbéliard les élus de la communauté
d'agglomération hésite entre prudence et
confiance
on a plus de 23 millions de kilomètres
derrière nos sans incident aucun donc
nous sommes extrêmement vigilants en
faisant très attention
nous lançons un audit mais nous n'avons
pas de raison aujourd'hui de penser que
ça soit le gaz lui même qui est causé
ces incidents la les bus au gaz
continueront donc de circuler jusqu'à
nouvel ordre à nice leur suspension
aurait laissé par jour soit 115 mille
personnes sur le trottoir le remorqueur
abeille flandre doit arriver dans la
soirée en corse pour pomper une nappe de
fioul qui menacent de polluer la place
de liamone dans le sud de l'île c'est un
yacht vous le voyez de 48 m de long
échoué près des côtes qui a occasionné
cette pollution
la nappe est longue d'un kilomètre et
demi et large de 500 m une cuve du
bateau contenant mille litres d'huile
est également endommagé
l'équipage et les passagers ont été
accueillis par la municipalité de sagan
et puis c'est un jardin extraordinaire
il se trouve près de cavalaire dans le
var
rien à voir avec les espaces verts à la
française ici sur 7 hectares en agence
les plantes venues de tous les pays à
climat méditerranéen pour en faire deux
un tableau samah soula guillaume michel
jean luc godard aurait pu y tourner le
mépris à deux détails près ici les
délais sont des plantes et leurs
rondeurs révèle parfois quelques
aspérités dans le rôle de l'amoureux
transi jean-michel 13 ans qu'il vénère
ce domaine
sept hectares qui évoque des jardins du
monde entier pourvu que leur climat soit
méditerranée comme au chili dans la
cordillère des andes à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
et quand vous voyez trois plantes
suffisent à faire un paysage n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une collection pour
évoquer la nature nouvelle zélande
afrique du sud californie des tableaux
que l'on visite dans cette propriété du
conservatoire du littoral
jadis maison d'été d'un grand
constructeur aéronautique
jean-michel les bichonne les attentions
ici pas de capricieuses ultra gâté ni
arrosages intempestifs ni engrais les
plantes sont quasiment rendu à leur état
sauvage
nous sommes au coeur de l'été les
plantes ne souffre pas contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire encore une
vision de l'esprit mais les plantes tout
simplement léthargie c'est à dire en
sommeil un des conditions climatiques
sont difficiles pour elle donc elles
vont attendre le retour de meilleures
conditions la pluie en clair cet automne
donc là elles sont en sommeil les
attendent
imaginez en un an le domaine utilisant
nos ce qu'une ville comme montpellier
consomme en un jour pour un rosé six
jardins publics
ici toutes les espèces ne viennent pas
du bout du monde pour évoquer certains
paysages on n'hésite pas à faire tout
simplement appel à des sosies il y à peu
jean michel a reçu l'ultime récompense
du jardinier cet arbre australien qui
l'a installé il ya dix ans à fleury pour
la première fois cette année on l'attend
avec impatience
on élève pendant des années pas qu'elle
meure les joueurs lyonnais
la pression c'est un peu une finalité
qui est enfin installé qu'elle s'exprime
la passion d'un homme la magie d'un lieu
dans une autre vie jean michel était
menuisier l'appel du bois vivant l'a
emporté sur le bois d'art direction
helsinki pour faire un point sur la
journée
décevant des français aux championnats
du monde d'athlétisme à commencer par
jean galfione
le perchiste a échoué aux portes de la
finale et met fin ainsi à sa carrière
sur place manuel tissier yann one jean
galfione les plus perchiste pour la
dernière fois il a rangé ses perches
dans leurs fourreaux femme parcourt sur
le sautoir d'helsinki balayés par les
rafales de vent en finlande
là où il a remporté sa première médaille
il ya onze ans galfione a tenté de
s'envoler une dernière fois la barre est
à 5 mètres 60 il y en aura plus d'autres
n'y a pas de tristesse c'est fini je
savais que c'était là c'était maintenant
et brutal mais il ya aucune mélancolie
je suis pas triste à 23 lions à 34 ans
galfione possède l'un des plus beaux
palmarès de l'athlétisme tricolore
champion olympique en 96 il devenait à
moscou en 99
champion du monde en salle et le seul
français à passer si m
va tenter aujourd'hui de relever un
nouveau défi les régates de la coupe de
l'america la journée est tout de même un
peu triste pour les bleus même si younis
barber s'est qualifié dans la douleur
pour la finale du saut en longueur
elle défendra son titre mondial grâce à
un saut à 6 mètres 60 de celle quarts
landais tel lui aussi grise mine des
trombes d'eau l'interview que le
programme ait plusieurs épreuves sont
reportés
et puis c'est une grande dame de
l'athlétisme qui vient de s'éteindre
colette besson est morte des suites d'un
cancer à laver 59 ans elle était entré
dans la légende en devenant championne
olympique du 400 m en 68 à mexico
christophe duchiron quand même un petit
peu le 6 juillet dernier à la rochelle
colette besson était affaibli fatigué
par la maladie et ce jour-là
terriblement déçu paris venait de perdre
les jeux olympiques de 2012 pour nous on
avait un doucier extraordinaire sa vie
d'une certaine manière c'était les jeux
les jeux de mexico en 1968 le 16 octobre
finale du 400 m le tour de piste qui la
révélera au prix d'une victoire
inattendue et magnifique qu'un quatrième
position mais tu es bien colette
maintenant il faut accélérer lé plus que
100 m ça y est me connecter pas vrai tu
vas gagner
non c'est prouvé colette besson
championne olympique forfait par frag
elle a 22 ans elle est médaille d'or sur
le podium elle rit elle pleure c'est
brune jeune femme qui va devenir vedette
du sport français
j'imagine qu'on va lui dire que le sport
s'était pas fait pour les femmes et elle
l a fait triompher d'une manière superbe
élégante et ça a été une victoire pour
le sport féminin
la france découvre un sourire éclatant
celui d'une maîtresse d'éducation
physique qui vise simplement à côté de
border no 69 elle battra le record du
monde du 400 m avec la française nicole
duclos
est-ce que tu t'étais sur le tour de
piste longtemps elle sera notre
référence jusqu'à la médaille d'or de
marie jo pérec aux jeux de barcelone en
92 et nous a précédés c'était c'était
comme une grande soeur voilà
colette besson avait la passion de
l'athlétisme et à vous affirmer de
l'élégance élégance de la foulée
élégance du coeur et sportive
authentique elle est décédé ce matin des
suites d'un cancer elle avait 59 ans une
semaine après l annonce de son retour en
équipe de france zinedine zidane se
confie au journal france football
il explique les raisons de son retour
une confession plutôt surprenante
puisqu'il parle d'une révélation
irrationnelle qui l'aurait amené à
prendre cette décision romain mais si
zinedine zidane entend des voix et c'est
peut-être celle de la raison qui l'a
fait revenir chez les bleus
ce matin dans l'hebdomadaire france
football il se confie et le propos est
pour le moins troublant une nuit à 3
heures du matin je me suis soudain
réveillé et là j'ai parlé avec quelqu'un
mais ça personne ne le sait ni ma femme
ni personne cette personne existe mais
ça vient de tellement loin
j'étais tout seul avec elle et chez moi
j'ai pris la vraie décision de revenir
j'étais comme interdit devant cette
force qui dicter ma conduite
avare en confidences zidane s'exprime
avant tout sur le terrain où il a
habitué son monde à des gestes hors du
commun
cette confession vérité qui accompagne
son retour détonne et étonne mais à la
fédération française de football
pas grand monde pour prendre le risque
de la commenter nul doute que le meneur
des bleus est sincère rien n'est due aux
sponsors et aux politiques tout vient de
l'intérieur
mais zidane a une image celle du zorro
du sauveur dieu est de retour s'est
exclamée la semaine dernière son
camarade thierry henry autant dire que
l'annoncé de cette révélation mystique
renforcent les attentes placées en lui
des buts des exploits et remettre
l'équipe de france en pleine lumière en
voile la première étape de la solitaire
du figaro entre perros guirec et bilbao
en espagne a été remportée par gildas
morvan le navigateur du finistère avait
déjà remporté le prologue
une victoire à l'arraché puisque le
deuxième bateau est arrivé qu'à une
minute 45 secondes plus tard la deuxième
étape conduira les 45 concurrents à la
rochelle un saint paul de vence dans les
alpes-maritimes la fondation maeght
propose cet été une exposition consacrée
aux estampes de braque accus roda les
oeuvres d'une vingtaine d'artistes
permettent de parcourir le 20e siècle
la gravure dans tous ses états un joli
voyage en couleurs que nous propose
isabelle bechler et delphine pas rick
miller sur les hauteurs de nice lové
dans la pinède
la fondation maeght abrite l'une des
plus belles collections privées d'art
moderne aimé maeght imprimeurs et
marchand d'art avait une relation très
étroite avec les grands artistes du
xxème siècle aujourd'hui encore la
galerie maeght accueille ces artistes
comme marco del rey dans l'atelier de
gravure du domaine ici on peints à
l'encré d'imprimerie et les machines
sont prestigieuses la presse fut
construite pour miro est signée par lui
marco travaille sur un monotype bien sûr
il ya aussi des tableaux ou des grains
papiers qui sont peints à la tmp lab la
gouache à l'huile mais la colère la
matière restent les reins surface
t'indiquer tous qui passe donc le surf
la presse que vous serez pas oublier
qu'il ya quand même une force un poids
de 3 tonnes c'est dans la matière c'est
complètement à l'intérieur du papier une
oeuvre unique donc mais passer par la
presse sa grande soeur est exposé à la
fondation à quelques mètres de là
l'exposition passe en revue un siècle de
gravure de marco del rey et aki kuroda
2005 on remonte jusqu à brac 1906 les
giacometti tapiès ribeyrolles miro tous
ont expérimenté tous les procédés de
reproduction tous les papiers tout les
gravures toutes les encres pour des
oeuvres jamais considéré comme mineur ou
les stands comme oeuvre à part entière
ça n'est pas du tout un produit dérivé
c'est vraiment un champ d'investigation
autonome libre avec des contraintes
techniques qui plaisent souvent aux
artistes des nouvelles couleurs des
nouveaux matériaux une réaction du
matériau qui les intéressent comme
calder inventaire en gravure l'illusion
de ses mobiles
giacometti crayonné sur la plaque de
cuivre comme sur du papier et braque a
souvent préfigurer ses sculptures dans
son oeuvre grave et voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci à vous de m'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo patrice
drevet 20h55 un film 100 mille dollars
au soleil avec jean paul belmondo et
lino ventura 12h50 le journal de la nuit
vous sera présentée par françois bonnet
dès 6h30 télématin dans les 4 vérités
jean-paul chatel recevra l'écrivain marc
levy et en ce qu'il sur ces images
surprenantes où le temps d'un spectacle
le toréador se transforme en acrobates
ces images régiront les plus sensibles
car le taureau au crest envie les
acrobates affronte jusqu'à six taureaux
environ 400 au kilo et ont pour seules
armes leur corps le public est
apparemment ravi et participe man 2 bon
coeur à la fête leksand soirée sur fond
de agm à 20 heures